i want to find out what you lovely
people would like to hear rap about so
uh everyone this is open to all of you
you don't know what what one second one
second
there are rules madam this is
it's hip-hop but it's british hip-hop
okay someone over here you said the
karma sutra um have you ever have you
ever used it
i'd like to know more about it you'd
like to know more about it
backstage
[Laughter]
okay okay does anyone own a copy of the
kamasutra
you can admit it's not you know it's
like
is this just a lot of like
guys with their partners being like well
i don't want to tell her where i've been
getting all my moves from
she knows no one's ever like should we
have sex where i hold you upside down
and also you have a red dot on your
forehead what is because it's an indian
indian it's an indian sex manual the
karma sutra um great the karma sutra
do you have any particular karma sutra
positions you want us to kind of focus
on for that
to stand back to back and the guy folds
it under
let's get him a suggestion from we went
to that so they got to come to this side
ancient egyptian pickup techniques oh
okay cool yeah
so you you mean like like chat up lines
and stuff everyone below the pharaoh how
did they pick up their girl everyone
below the pharaoh of course because yeah
because the pharaoh could just be like
i'm the pharah [ __ ] i'm the
fairest of them all
you come up with a better pharaoh pun in
half a second
ancient egyptian pickup techniques great
um
that wasn't actually from this little
enclave here so i want to give you guys
another chance what would you like to
wrap up
oh
it started out so nice didn't it
ah a rescue dog ball in a meth
what breeds this this dog
she's a mark of course she is this that
was answered so quickly that it makes me
feel like this is not a hypothetical
situation
what what'd you call a bluey or
something
um
foxy yeah cool
cool okay foxy the born in a methylab
where was the meth lab was it like biker
meth or
foxy the dog born in a arizona meth lab
ancient edition pick-up techniques in
the karma sutra let's come people who
are kind of at the back of the room i
want to get involved with you guys
syndrome
was what was the first word
oh putin's short man syndrome yeah
because he is like five six or something
isn't he which you know
it's very sad let's not bring it up in a
comedy show
um cool uh putin's short man syndrome
great uh let's get one final suggestion
this come from anywhere but i i might
reject it if i think it shakes
i love the
belting uptick at the end a condom with
a top hat it makes me think there's a
sequel to this suggestion a condom with
a top hat trying to board the titanic
i know it's a condom it's a condom with
a top hat that is a good suggestion
um a condom with a top hat ancient
egyptian pick-up techniques putin's
short man syndrome the karma sutra and
foxy the dog from the arizona meth lab
she's a mum and she was rescued um great
this is going to be really fun
now because sometimes the suggestions
are bad and then the wrap is the
audience's fault right so
[Music]
i have so many beats on here i want to
yeah i want to use this one
feel the tension in the room
can he freestyle yes of course he can
we've seen him do it already but it's
going to be more exciting now because
it's about the karma sutra that's how
we're going to start
urethra put it up inside that's a nice
little position getting the friction and
then emitting the emission emitting the
emission use the same word twice i look
for my nice indian sex advice i'm
opening the draw on what comes next is
filed right beside the joy of sex that's
the more modern day with the weird
illustrations
no hesitation this guy lying on the bed
with the lady on top she's got an
elephant head that's kind of weird still
i like how they do because it's written
by the indians and they're hindus and
they choose to do it maybe doggy style
what's the doggy's name not foxy i'm in
denial i'm asking that alive in the meth
lab with sad people bring her over here
they're like have you tested the meth
and she'd be like woof they're like you
wanna taste this tell me the truth and
she's like
and she's bitching
they're like this is good meth we can
make some cash in arizona
[Music]
[Laughter]
hallucinates everything you get back
home like what is she doing she's pissed
on the rug she's pissed on the kitchen
floor i'm assuming when you do meth you
do more urination or some type of
defecation if i'm there in the egyptian
nation i'm like sup pharaoh what can i
do
i'm like sup lady i really love your
smile i'm gonna make you wet like the
river nile that's my pickup technique
sticking ahead they had two niles one
was white and one was red and one means
seven days of the month she won't let
you enter you really can't confront and
so i say yeah i want to put a thing on
then i'm going into your kingdom yeah i
wrap it up so there's never any kids my
dick's weirdly shaped like a pyramid
she's like what i try and keep a
straight face i'm like it's thin at the
top but it's wide at the base just like
i don't really think i really want you
to slide i'm like babe there's treasure
inside when i unfurl it she sees my
ding-a-ling like howard carter i see
marvelous things that's a real niche
reference a deep cut to the tomb the
valley of the kings that's the name for
her womb anyway i get kicked out the
door remember like the condom that i
said before yeah it looks fancy what's
that it's a british penis so it wears a
top hat oh hello i'm adoring i'm made of
latex and dressed like an edwardian a
fine man i'll never let my head go bare
i always keep a top hat and then a
second spare i call it double wrapping i
keep it very safe probably you're
picturing a mustache on my face yes a
top hat and king of the hill is the
condom empty unused or is it filled who
knows full to the brim that's a
[Laughter]
because mercury was used in hat
production the milliners of stockport
used it in the construction millennium
means hat maker not someone with lots of
pounds who's a billionaire he be ground
down he's like hello i'm going and
shooting
man
[Applause]